Freitas in the bg5 neighborhood market
count their losses and rebuild while
reconstruction work starts more trouble
is threatened vigilantes who are
protecting traders in the community are
no longer welcome the Borah UN Committee
decrees the traders have set up a crisis
committee which is empowered to declare
war on the armed groups we gave them a
48-hour ultimatum to surrender their
weapons and reintegrate into the
community the don't surrender we will
resume hostilities with them government
authority has to be restored in a pk5
neighborhood that threat is what's
making people here nervous fighting
started on Tuesday when an armed militia
man was killed when he refused to pay a
shopkeeper for an item he wanted his
group retaliated and our course of three
days 40 people were killed and dozens
are in hospital 40 shops in the market
were destroyed people in this market in
the pk5 neighborhood say militias have
long been exporting traders here and the
actual banners that broke out last week
one the first in 2018 the United Nations
Mission in central Africa attempted to
stop extortion it failed by the time its
operations is over more than 40 people
have me killed
the United Nations mission here is
struggling to keep the peace more troops
are patrolling the area but they might
not be able to deal with a major attack
the main issue is that there is no local
forces police and military then we were
also obliged to send to established an
operational base in the area our forces
are conducting patrols all along with a
fire but then we don't have enough force
there we still need to increase families
on both sides are left to mourn their
dead and fear more attacks the Central
African Republic entered civil war that
started in 2013
and killed thousands of people since
then more than a million of the five
million population have been forced from
their homes many have fled abroad for
now there is an uneasy calm on the
streets of bangy but as everyone here
knows it will only take a spark to
ignite another wave of killings in a
country where warlords controlled more
territory than the government ahmadiyya
trees al jazeera Bangi